okay so on this quest to do these things
right introducing this new language okay
we have some abbreviations to make a
little subheading place abbreviation
which basically help us to use this
language but do it in a much sort of
more efficient way in the same way as
we've got words like you're not drop
this down we have words like don't write
don't is actually not a word don't is
two words that we've kind of crammed
together and it's faster to say don't
then do not write and so we've got a
whole bunch of these kind of like
contractions and abbreviations that just
help us work a little bit better
so I'm going to give you I've got one
two three four five little abbreviations
that I'm going to show you okay so the
first one is the one that the killer was
mentioning I'm gonna use this example in
that two times pain if you've got a
pretty room I'm gonna label a variable
and you multiply it by a number two
times P I'm just gonna write that as B
right
it's just like saying Oh instead of
saying I have two of these whiteboard
boxes I could just say I have to buckle
memories does that make sense
so it's just kind of cutting that out
it's a bit of an abbreviation is kaity
for us in the same way we know that if
you've got like division we already have
a fraction symbol you're familiar with
so for instance I might say e divided by
four I could write that as and that's an
abbreviation you're already very
familiar with we also at the start of
the year we looked at index notation do
you remember that like when you square
or cube the number okay so for instance
if I wanted to say have a number
people if I wanted two times two times
two I'd say too cute well here I just
have a label kind of standing in for
that so how could we write this in a
short way s3 the P oh okay
interestingly what I'm doing is I'm
multiplying right if I had three and
then P like this that would be P plus P
plus P right but here I'm multiplying
two times to see what would you do
instead
okay PE and what you gotta say cute or ^
3 and those were a little bit different
like that this versus don't understand
this is this big kind of different okay
right this is 3 times P but this is P
times itself three times and they're a
little bit different okay I have a
handful more for you okay if you do
index notation here I only got two more
things if I just have one watt or
something right like say one load of
what they have before a one more name 1
1 of something is just the same size as
that number yeah so one line 5 is 5 1
lot of 6 6 1 lot of 34 million ok so I
don't need to say 1 times I can just say
that number okay
whatever that happens to be and one last
one see this guy here if you want want
to take out multiplication signs you can
take out a whole bunch of your life so
for instance if I had something like a
times B times 6
for instance if I just use the first
rule how could I write that yeah okay
interestingly you've gone straight to
the answer that I do want but
interestingly it's not the most obvious
knots on I think we get this I would
have written a be 6 like it's just you
want it there okay
now the first question is how can I just
change the order why is a B 6 and 6a v
why are they actually
the same thing yeah this is okay so
we're trying to have to make it argument
about which one's most significant they
get pause on that one because I don't
think it's always true but it might be
can I get some other suggestions yeah
correct I'm comparing this and this so
in the last couple of days right we've
looked at the fact that multiplication
you can multiply numbers in whatever you
want right you can do these ones first
what would you do these ones so the
order can change to be whatever we like
however we're adesh was right in the
first place
we do tend to put the number at the
front I will say it's not always because
the numbers are less the important
suppose a and B will like six billion
and 40 trillion right I would think that
the six billion in the point trillion
are more important numbers than the six
but we don't know what they are
okay so by convention so it all kind of
talking a common language we abbreviate
in this way in what's the same way that
we all agree that don't means do not
like why do we do that
well at least that way we're all talking
the same language and when you say that
I know what you mean and when I say that
you know what I mean yes you could yes
you could
but again just as a convention to make
things nice of me we tend to put if
we've got lots of labels if you've got
lots of pretty rules we tend to put them
in alphabetical order right you don't
have to as you just noticed you can
multiply them whichever you order you
like but that way if they're all the
same order we can look at each other's
working and know that were on the right
track okay so see what we've done all
we're trying to do here is work with
numbers when we're not sure what they
are or identify patterns that are true
for not just some numbers but all of
them like here